well let's go straight to our deputy
political editor sam coates who is uh in
downing street outside number 10. uh sam
already rumors uh flying around what do
we know
well we won't get confirmation until a
little bit late this afternoon when we
see cabinet ministers about to be
appointed in post walking up the famous
street uh but at the moment we're just
in the slightly more gruesome phase of a
cabinet reshuffle the sackings we don't
know who it's going to be but as we
speak boris johnson has returned after
pmq's to his office behind the speaker's
chair and that's where he will hold the
more difficult conversations with
members of his top team some of whom
will no longer be members of his top
team in the first big reshuffle of his
cabinet in 18 months so what do we
expect well there are rumors about all
corners of the cabinet including the
great offices of state will pretty patel
remain home secretary after all the
criticism of the way that the home
office has handled the migrant boat
situation boats coming in over the
channel in increasingly large numbers
with her seemingly unable to stem the
flow will dominic raab remain the
foreign secretary the crisis in
afghanistan he acted like a lightning
rod for lots of criticism over over him
his uh
holiday the way he handled the situation
some in tory circles asking whether he
is suited to the foreign office he's the
first secretary of state he's a deputy
prime minister in albert name he stood
in for boris johnson last year when
boris johnson had to go to hospital with
covid but the criticism over the last
few weeks has been stinging will dominic
rob survive then other names in the top
tier of the cabinet gavin williamson
probably the most often mentioned the
embattled education secretary he's had
to deal with the difficult situation on
schools often with stumbling media
performances
and criticism about the decisions that
kind of back and forth the hokey cokey
about whether or not schools would
remain open through the pandemic much of
the decision making of course foisted
upon him by number 10 but nevertheless
widely expected not to remain in that
post the test for some in his own party
is whether or not he leaves government
altogether and is sacked because of what
some perceive as poor performance or
whether or not boris johnson who relied
on gavin williamson to get elected
actually survived in another role he
knows northern ireland very well could
he end up as the secretary of state
there other embattled ministers could
hang on or could go we're looking at
people like robert genwright reports
over the weekend that his flagship
housing policy looks likely to be
significantly watered down in the face
of opposition who could be the winners
uh well one name often mentioned is liz
trust currently the trade secretary
she's been doing the first of those
series of international trade deals most
notably with australia she's looking to
start work with america but she has been
very highly rated amongst the party
could she go up if a vacancy uh it does
uh open up that could be uh possibly
even the foreign office should boris
johnson look kindly upon her and then
there are all sorts of other questions
most notably one of the most mercurial
figures in government michael gove he is
the cabinet office minister which is a
minister in charge of the inner workings
of government huge amount of speculation
perhaps some of it driven by him and his
allies that he could end up with a big
promotion in this reshuffle maybe as
home secretary certainly we're here
reports that he's been sniffing around
police reform and other key areas but
could michael gove who famously stabbed
boris johnson in the front in 2016
really get a big promotion at this point
in time not least because just yesterday
in cabinet boris johnson handed michael
gave a bit of a new role making sure
that the shortages uh that the uh the
delays at the border the delays with hgv
drivers delivering goods to this country
and the shortages on the shelves aren't
going to continue to christmas so if
michael gove's getting new roles as
recently as yesterday will he be moving
up or will he be staying in that
slightly odd role as cabinet office
minister another long-standing minister
that we don't know the future of brandon
lewis he's in the northern ireland
secretary
big change in northern ireland obviously
affected uh by brexit you've got
political change there with the dep
tanking in the polls big questions of
what will happen in northern ireland in
the may elections where stormont goes to
the polls uh will boris johnson want to
reset the relationship uh over there or
has his work trying to calm tensions
that actually uh played off uh and boris
johnson decides to keep brandon lewis in
post uh one person two people who are
almost certain to be safe well there's
sanjay javid uh he's the new health
secretary the last time we were standing
in downing street doing a reshuffle it
was sanjay javid being sacked as
chancellor in a row curiously enough
about who should be his advisors that
was the height of the dominic cummings
era now sajid javid back in favor and
given that he's only been in post a few
weeks after the departure of matt
hancock he is almost certain to stay
another person probably feeling more
comfortable than most uh well that is
soella braverman she was only
reappointed
as attorney general last week after
coming back off maternity leave so
unless she gets promoted it would be
very strange indeed for her not to stay
in her job there are other cabinet
figures that have been the subject of
some speculation like jacob rees-mogg
he's currently the commons leader some
had thought he might go in as number two
in the treasury which of course is a
cabinet level uh job that could uh free
up that commons leader job another
alternative uh for gavin williamson so
all sorts of speculation today the
question is what does boris johnson
think the aim of his reshuffle is he is
in a strong position at the moment he's
just carried out long delayed reforms to
social care he's about to have his party
confidence he will have been stung by
some of the the criticism that his
cabinet can be quite low powered so
looking according to that statement that
you just talked about uh to refresh his
top team to make it look like he's on
the front foot just to the point where
the polls uh suggest the conservatives
are enjoying a little bit of a dip
after those tax rises that he announced
so he's looking at a new cabinet in
order to go forward to the next
political season who could be the
winners uh well some of the names that
have been in the frame to go up in this
reshuffle figures like the minister
kemi badenock she had been tipped
for the education brief she has played
quite a strong role in the culture war
narrative of the last few months but
also is highly regarded inside downing
street former spectator employee she's
tipped to go up
victoria atkins uh said to have
impressed she just got a little bit
added to her brief looking after uh
afghan refugees when they come to the uk
uh to resettle uh another name that
could uh could go up uh oliver dowden is
the culture minister could he uh often
often see as a backroom figure actually
move into a bigger brief uh after uh
tending that uh culture media sport and
digital role uh one of the uh births for
him could be the education department
and then there's the question really of
who gets sacked all together from
cabinet uh if you need to bring people
in that you have to get people out of
your top task that will be the job that
boris johnson is doing as we speak and
then in a few hours we will learn the
winners